اليوم نستضيفه من القاهره الخبير الدولية
وخبير القانون الدولي العام الدكتور ايمن
سلامه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور ايمن نبدا بهذا
الاقرار لمجلس اليوم نواب الروسيه قرار
بتعليق مشاركه موسكو في معاهده نيو ستارت
انهيار اذا لاخر معاهده نوويه باقيه بين
واشنطن وموسكو ما المخاوف
صحيح مخاوف عديده ولكن دعيني احدد يعني
الشق القانوني في مساله التعليق ساسفنشن
لهذه الاتفاقيه الاخيره ما بين القطبين
النوويين الولايات الامريكيه من جانب وعلى
الطرف الاخر روسيا الفيدراليه التعليق لا
يعني انسحاب ولا يعني ايضا اناء ولكن
التعليق يعني ان لا تزال روسيا متمسكه بكل
النصوص وهذا ما اكدته الخارجيه الروسيه
اليوم على لسان نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
اليوم في لقائه مع لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
الروسيه في الدومه ولكن في نفس الوقت يعلق
مؤقتا
ارتباطاته وتعهدته الدوليه بموجب هذه
الاتفاقيه ولكن من الناحيه العملي تفضل
معنى ذلك ان وهذا هو تصريح الروس اننا
سنلتزم التزام راسخ تصريح اليوم
بالتعهداتنا بموجب هذا الاتفاقيه ولكن في
حال التزم الطرف الاخر في هذا الاتفاقيه
بذات
حسن النوايا والالتزامات وان هم يجعلوا
المفتشون الروسي
يصل الى المواقع الرؤوس النوويه ووسائل
الايصال النوويه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما حدث في الاربع اعوام
الاخيره ولكن كانت علقت من الناحيه
الواقعيه من الجانب الروسي تفتيش
النزرائهم المفتشون
النوويون للولايات الامريكيه علقت منذ ما
قبل وباء كوفيد 19 هذه التفتيشات الدينيه
الميدانيه بموجب هذه الاتفاقيه نيو ستارد
لذلك المخاوف ستكون ليست قانونيه ولكن
المخاوف ممكن نفرض لها وقت وهي مخاوف
عملياتيه ميدانيه سياسيه طيب
منصب نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي قال ان
هذه الخطوه هي رد تاخر كثيرا على مصافه
بانه اعلان حرب عمل لماذا يعتبر هذا هذه
تعتبر هذه الخطوه كرد علامه المتحده ما
يعني ما المغزى ما المفهوم من هذا الرد
يعني انا دعيني حتى اكون خبير محايد او
ضيف محايد اقول الرد الامريكي على تصريحات
نائب بوزير خارجيه لروسيا تحدثوا ان
الاتفاقيه بقى لها سنوات لماذا ناتي الان
ونتحدث عن ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا تبدي تفهم حسنيه لا تلتزم بهذا هكذا
معاهده دوليه بين الطرفين لماذا ده راي
لمولات المتحده الامريكيه المسؤولون لماذا
تاخر مثل هذا التفسير او التوضيح او
التعليق ولكن
لا يعد يعني من وجهه نظر القانون الدولي
لا يعد هذا التصريح من جانب روسيا
بما يسمى اعلان الحرب بين الناحيه
القانونيه
والنظريه اعلان الحرب هو اعلان الحرب لا
توجد يعني مناور
التحركات اجراءات على الارض تسمى باعلان
حرب وهو ما لم يفعله الرئيس الروسي حتى
هذه اللحظه وتجنب مقوله قانونيه او ادعاء
قانوني الحرب حينه دشن واعلن ما يسمى فيه
الرابع وعشرين من فبراير العام المنصرم ما
سماه الرئيس بوتين عمليه عسكريه خاصه
محدوده روسيه في داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ولكن ما بين هلالين هو بمثابه بدء حرب
بالفعل بموجب الميدان وليس بموجب القانون
الترسانه النوويه لكل من بريطانيا وفرنسا
في اي اتفاقات او اتفاقيات مستقبليه للحد
من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه بين روسيا
والغرب كيف تقراون ذلك ما معنى ذلك لابد
من ادراج دول
على باقي دول العالم يتحدث عن ايران على
سبيل المثال على الهند وباكستان يعني ما
مخاطر خطوه هذه
فهو مطلب شرعي من جانب الاتحاد الروسي
لروسيا الفيدراليه هذا مطلب شرعي ان يتم
تضمين كل الدول النوويه ولا تقتصر هذه
الاتفاقيه على القطبين النوعين الامريكيه
وروسيا الفيدراليه ولكن من جانب الاخر
فالروس عفوا الخبراء الامريكيين في هذا
الحقل او هذا المدرك يصرون على الرئيس
يشيرونا على الرئيس الامريكي بايدن بان
تكون هناك ايضا اجراءات تجاه الصين
الشعبيه التي اعلنت رسميا انها ستزيد من
عدد رؤوسها النوويه
لذات الحد الذي بلغته روسيا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
اشتراكا بموجب الاتفاقيه وهو 1550 راس
نووي و700 وسيله ايصال لهذه الروس النوويه
هناك مخاوف امريكيه تجاه
شعبيه هناك مطالب مشروعه ايضا من جانب
روسيا الفيدراليه تجاه تضمين دول اكثر في
هذه الاتفاقيه ولا ريب انت الى غضاضه من
جانب رايي القانوني لا غضب ولا تثريب ان
تتحول هذا الاتفاقيه الثنائيه الى اتفاقيه
مالتي ناشونال اتفاقيه
متعدده الاطراف طيب سؤال ربما الذي يعني
يطرحه الكثيرون ما الجدول من هذه
المعاهدات يعني في خضم هذه الصراعات هناك
دائما رؤساء يستبعدون الحاجه او الاستخدام
لهذه الاسلحه فما الهدف من هذه من هذه
المعاهدات ولماذا يعد التوجه نحو التسليح
نوع من الحمايه والدفاع يعني كيف نفهم هذا
التناقض
لولا المعاهده الدوليه او ايه معاهده
دوليه لا كان اي طرف اي دوله او منظمه
دوليه تخرق القانون الدولي تنتهك
الاتفاقيات المبرمه وتتحدث انه لا يوجد
قيد او يعني يعني لا يوجد قيود او حدود
على الدوله ذات السياده الهدف من هذا
الاتفاقيه وهي الوحيده الباقيه هو تحديد
اقصى سقف زنمي زمني تستطيع القوتين
النويتتين الوصول اليه سواء كان 1550 او
700 اذا لم تكن هناك 700 وسيله ايصال نووي
ان لم تكن هذه الاتفاقيه المهمه في مجال
حمايه السلم والامن الدوليه ووقايه كلا
الدولتين في المقام الاول وفي الصداره من
اي التهديدات باستخدام اسلحه نوويه وكان
الرئيس بوتين هدد بذلك في بدايه هذه الحرب
ان لم تكن مثل هكذا اتفاقيه لا تجاوزت
وتخطط كلتا الدولتين روسيا الفيدراليه من
جنوب
عدد اضعاف هذه الاعداد المحدده ب 1550 راس
نووي و700 فقط وسيله ايصال وكان المشهد
اللي هو حتى الان خطير لكان اخطر ومن حيث
المبدا هو عدد كبير يعني ويكفي بتدمير
الكره الارضيه برمتها واقل من ذلك يعني
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ايمن سلامه شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور ايمن سلامه الخبير
القانوني القانون الدولي العام القاهره
شكرا جزيلا لك